you know black don't crack right no it
don't look at this look at this look at
this what's up y'all I'm deja and I'm
Pedro we're here at the 2016 Beatty
Awards and we're gonna play the black
don't crack quiz man let's do it come on
ready let's see what's up
which Pharrell Williams is younger oh
this is hard
Hey look at the same desperella in the
future and that's real in the pants
ain't nothing on from the present I know
that's the younger one cuz you got a pro
on that's because he washing his face
with cold water I read a lot about
Pharrell which Gabrielle Union is
younger I don't want to get in trouble
picking the wrong one bro that's my baby
right there yeah okay yes beautiful see
my eyes didn't see which one I was
looking at it was the wrong way which
Angela Bassett is younger oh that's hard
is not easy no
yes I know because her she knows that
haircut now either falling out aw I
gotta go with their short - I know I
know Oh beautiful
I love me some Angela I want to marry
Angela Bassett no problem put your right
black don't crap it we just flip it in
the Sun look like with the fried chicken
I love being black I'm black and I'm
proud hold on Wow look at me
I'm Melanie